reste son plan fixe pour l'instant à la
safim action tournage au coeur du
quartier du stade à chalon sur saône
une scène de plus en plus courante pour
bilel son assistante et ses apprentis
comédiens ils se retrouvent les
week-ends et pendant les vacances pour
se consacrer à leur passion est un peu
hésitant tuera genre quand tu t'es levé
il faut que
remontée des coûts de presse avec leurs
associations citées créatif
créée en 2015 ils se rassemblent autour
d'un projet commun
le tournage de courts métrages une façon
d'apprendre à vivre ensemble mais aussi
à mettre en avant les talents de chacun
on va tout compris qu'il prépare
peut-être bouzid et olly gan à 27 ans un
vilain se définit lui même avec humour
comme le spielberg les cycles est
considéré comme le grand frère il veut
aider les jeunes à grandir et à croire
en un avenir basket se passer quoi la
vidéo depuis tout petit j'ai grandi ici
dans ce quartier et je vais évoluer donc
ouais ça ça me tient à coeur de faire ce
tournage ici parce que ce café et
commence à être un peu abandonné donc on
essaye de garder le cap de croire la
résurrection du quartier en quelque
sorte et a beaucoup de talent il ya
beaucoup de des personnes qui sont se
motiver pour s'en sortir pour réussir
dans la vie omar malienne et bachar
également du quartier du stade sont là
depuis le début
et récemment d'autres membres sont
arrivés extérieurs à la cité comme
louise de saint loup de varennes et anne
de chalon sur saône
je travaille dans ce sens là pour aller
au devant de l'autre tout le temps aller
au devant de l'autre sans peur sans
crainte
j'ai confiance est vraiment j'ai été
attiré par sa démarche qui semblait
identique à la mienne je pense qu'on est
plus forts ensemble que diviser grâce à
facebook en fait j'ai vu bilel qui monte
cette association
avoir quelqu'un à chalon qui regroupe
des personnes pour échanger partager des
choses ensemble ça n'a vraiment plus tôt
dans la matinée
tous s'étaient retrouvés dans le snack
d'un ami pour préparer le tournage de
l'après midi un temps de travail
nécessaire à l'exigence qu'il s'impose
il conduire la scène
là vous qui va parler des vidéos buzz
sur facebook
oui je reviens on fait pareil tu vois
les gars moi ça fait une heure choses à
temps les ai tous c'est aussi le moment
pour ses amis de revenir sur l' aventure
site et créatif
le mois dernier l'association a reçu le
prix du meilleur film associatif
après avoir participé à un concours sur
youtube de quoi donner encore plus de
motivation à ces jeunes
j'aimerais tourner des films enfin
talange et je trouve au début c'était
bill et le besoin de quelques acteurs on
sait proposer puis ça nous a plu on a
continué on a continué s'est pas arrêté
ouais ça nous a fait voir beaucoup de
choses n'allaient à paris on a vu des
trucs que jamais on aurait pu penser
voire de la dgi change que tu envie
d'aller encore plus loin
de plus réussir ce domaine de l'espoir
un espoir alimenté aussi par les
subventions reçues de la politique de la
ville la caf ou le fonds de
participation des habitants et qui les
pousse à tourner toujours plus de vidéos
antonio les encadre avec bilel depuis le
début c'est surtout pour aider les
jeunes ont un peu plus âgés donc un peu
plus mature on est là pour les épauler
surtout pour leur montrer leur apprendre
les suivre donc
on a un rôle plutôt important de ce côté
là on en fait voir d'autres horizons
avec le cinéma les jeunes ne l'ont
confié il rêve maintenant d'aller au
festival de cannes alors ils vont
continuer à tourner et à délivrer leur
message à tout ça
grote à vis des vidéos qui peut se la
voit les deux gamins la caisse beth
parce que paris 22 quemener versement du
coup mais le pire c'est le déficit de
dieu vous avez probablement plus de 100
sur vos mains d'un conscient qu'on
n'aura jamais le dvd qui a pris des
armes pour essayer de janvier fort du
jour désespoir ne soyez pas du mauvais
côté à l'école je vais pas vous en prie
pour ça elle est passée où la fraternité
tu veux nous descendre afin tu manques
le monde a faim bientôt la fin du monde
[Musique]